problema 28 cuál ecuación representa
mejor la parte de la gráfica que se
muestra y aquí nos pone en esta gráfica
de acá vamos a ver las opciones en la
opción a tenemos ya igual a 1.75 x esto
simplemente es una recta es una recta
con pendiente positiva tanto la opción a
como la opción c tienen rectas es un
número x x y entonces no se verían así
se verían como líneas rectas por ejemplo
la opción a se vería como una recta
creciente que va de abajo a la izquierda
hacia arriba a la derecha y la opción c
se vería como una recta decreciente como
algo así sale con pendiente 1.5 y menos
1.5 respectivamente entonces estas
opciones no son vamos a ver las otras
dos en la opción b tenemos ye igual a
1.75 x al cuadrado ésta suena un poco
mejor porque ya tenemos ahora así un x
al cuadrado la gráfica de x al cuadrado
se ve como una parábola verdad eso es
algo que ya has visto antes
se ve más o menos como algo así como
algo de este estilo sale y este factor
de acá el factor 1.75 simplemente hace
que la subida sea más pronunciada en vez
de venir así viene como un poco más
flaca se sube más rápido y eso es más o
menos lo que tenemos aquí en el primer
cuadrante entonces la opción que estamos
buscando es la b y la opción se no
funciona porque tiene este signo menos
de acá que lo que hace es voltear esa
parábola si nos fijamos en la gráfica de
menos x al cuadrado tendríamos algo de
este estilo y el factor 1.75 haría otra
vez que fuera más pronunciada ahora en
este caso la bajada vale entonces ésta
tampoco es por lo tanto la respuesta es
b vamos aquí abajo
dice luisa escribió un ensayo de mil
palabras a una razón de 20 palabras por
minuto y empezó a escribirlo a las 6 20
pm y no tomó ningún descanso guau qué
trabajadora a qué hora terminó de
escribir su ensayo lisa bueno pues es un
ensayo de mil palabras mil mil palabras
y nos dice que escribe a veinte palabras
por minuto
entonces para encontrar cuántos minutos
se tardó tenemos que tomar estas mil
palabras mil palabras y dividirlas entre
la razón a la cual escribe veinte
palabras por minuto por minuto
sale esto de aquí es igual a vamos a
hacer 1000 entre 20 lo puedes hacer
mentalmente por ejemplo puedes decir 100
entre 20 es 5 entonces mil entre 20 y 50
pero si no lo quieres hacerme
mentalmente también lo puedes hacer con
división de casitas aquí podemos poner
mil dividido entre 20 20 cabe cinco
veces en 105 por 20 de 100 aquí restamos
nos queda 0 baja el 0 20 cabecero veces
en cero otra vez quedan ceros y aquí
queda 0 y por lo tanto la respuesta otra
vez es 50 y para ajustar las unidades
palabras se cancela con palabras minutos
está en el denominador del denominador
por lo tanto sube acá como minutos
minutos y entonces se tarda 50 minutos
si te confundió un poco eso de las
unidades no te preocupes basta con con
hacer esta cosa intuitiva de dividir mil
entre 20 y saber que hasta el final nos
tienen que quedar minutos vale bueno
esto es lo que tarda y nos dicen que
empezó a las 6 20 de las 6 20 de las 6
20 pm
a las 7 a las 7 pm son 40 minutos verdad
son 40
porque cada hora tiene 60 minutos pero
trabajo 50 entonces terminó a las 7 10
terminó a las siete de la tarde con diez
minutos va eso es la opción de muy bien
siguiente problema
siguiente problemas nos preguntan a qué
es igual x a la quinta cuando x es igual
a menos 2
bueno pues elevar algo a la quinta es
multiplicar los cinco veces es decir
tendríamos que hacer menos 2 x menos 2 x
menos 2 x menos 2 x menos 2 y aquí
podríamos hacer la multiplicación o
bueno sabes que vamos a hacer la
multiplicación así por pura diversión
menos 2 x menos dos es cuatro luego
cuatro por menos 12 es menos 8 porque
más por menos es menos menos ocho por
menos 12 16 porque menos por menos es
más
16 por 12 32 y con este menos es menos
32 y por lo tanto la respuesta sería
menos 32 o sea la opción
y si quieres hacer esto así súper rápido
puedes darte cuenta que dos a la quinta
es 32 y después nada más ponerle el
signo adecuado como tenemos un exponente
impar entonces va a quedar negativo
entonces nos quedaría menos 32 sale
observa empezamos con menos con otro
menos se hace más con otros se hace
menos con otro más y con otro menos si
tenemos un exponente impar nos queda
menos si tuviéramos un exponente par nos
quedaría con signo positivo vale
entonces la respuesta es menos 32 muy
bien déjame bajar aquí
dice este problema el 31 la siguiente
gráfica compara el peso de un objeto en
la tierra con su peso en la luna ok
aquí está en libras aquí también está en
libras ok entonces mira más o menos si
tenemos algo que pesa 150 libras
aproximadamente va a pesar como 25 en la
luna es más o menos la sexta parte la
sexta parte sale bueno déjame bajar para
ver la pregunta dice cuál es el peso
aproximado en la luna de un astronauta
que pesa 120 libras en la tierra ok
entonces si tenemos un cierto peso en la
tierra ya dijimos que es más o menos
como un sexto su peso en la luna
entonces si pesa 120 libras en la tierra
pesa como 20 libras en la luna 20 libras
en la luna esto lo hicimos con esta
aproximación pero también pues podemos
ver la gráfica lo que podemos hacer es
tomar las 120 libras lo ponemos en el
eje de peso en la tierra que es más o
menos como por aquí
como por aquí y vemos cuánto nos dice
esta gráfica que vale tenemos que ir
para acá y eso sería aproximadamente
como 19 aquí es 15 así como 19 y muy
cerca de 20 entonces de estas opciones
la que mejor queda es 20 libras vale 20
libras si quisiéramos hacerlo al revés y
saber cuánto debe pesar un objeto en la
tierra para que pese exactamente 20
libras en la luna tendríamos que empezar
justo en esta intersección y de ahí
bajar y quizás nos quede tantito más a
la derecha como no sé por 121 122 libras
pero bueno respondiendo a esta pregunta
el peso aproximado en la luna del
astronauta de 120 libras es de 20 libras
o sea la opción b